you
golf with these teeth with the man
sector 23 evac complete proceeding to
sector 25 that's you we are def don't
please remember to use formal
dedications went on UPR calm rides are
on the sector 23 evac transit to vector
25 confirmed
Roger that dampier rocks
Nova SATA support what's the view up
ahead your combat air space push to be
some generate on the ground if you click
the head they are engaged with pharrell
fee and imperial forces this isn't good
they're about to get glass Nova bring us
around and get ready to pop the hatch
given that the rapidly degenerating the
state of the star when I get there
degenerate hating anyway the current
state of aggression necessitates a
window of operations our orders from you
PR can require us to focus our
evacuation efforts exclusively on you p
our soldiers have we thought through
every tactical advantage here Nova we
might lose pin arc but there's still
another fight ahead mathematically
speaking the generate rebels would
provide a tactical improvement against
the ver el c however if i were to
calculate their odds of survival based
on the current numbers of crawl and
morel fee they are facing along with our
don't care if we're going to stand any
chance of winning we would improve our
odds with that kind of firepower on our
team turn us around
also command requesting emergency evac
of generate rebels in Sector 24 again
and QPR command captain QPR commander
Gulf request denied proceed to sector 25
commander we need everyone we can spare
from the way they're decimating for LC
and Imperium forces on the ground I
think their loyalty is proven I repeat
you be our command the knife is request
generate cannot be trusted UPR command
we need to evac now pin arc is almost
fully darkened these warriors won't
stand a chance if we leave now open for
debate captain you have your orders
besides I've just called in an orbital
strike on this target in five micron
there won't be anything left for you to
pick up an orbital strike commander
these heroes could aid our cause if your
head straight Katherine you are
guidelines thing that we can't leave any
supplies or tech or hostile to make use
of after we pull out we're clearing the
area proceed to sector 25 immediately
get your ship away from the strike zone
command Nova
experiencing some difficulty
musky irregularities caused by this uh
or LC darkening nose being moved into
position we've got to do an emergency
touchdown to ensure everything is
operating correctly that is UPR protocol
correct captain cult you're violating a
great as hat Nova prepare for you back
did someone call for a lift look like
you guys could use a hand we have the
situation under control so I'll take
that as a thank you and where will you
be taking us captain gulped isn't it
I'll explain once we get off this rock
think you might be interested in a
rendezvous I have planned with another
generate defective and a few other
friends yeah I think it might be time to
give them the call